الحرب خدعه وتكتيكات القصف بهذه الطريقه
التقليديه ربما اصبح من الماضي او لنقل
يجب ان توازيه خطه مبتكره فكلما ابدعت
طرقا جديده للقتال زاد حظك للتقدم في
ميدان المواجهه
يبدو ان اوكرانيا تعلمت الدرس جيدا بعد
اكثر من عام وثلاثه اشهر على بدايه الحرب
اقامت شبكه من العملاء والمتعاطفين داخل
روسيا للعمل على تنفيذ هجمات ضد اهداف
روسيه عبر المسيرات وفق مصادر مخابراتيه
هؤلاء العملاء الموالون لاوكرانيا داخل
روسيا نفذوا هجوم المسيره على الكرملين في
اوائل شهر مايو الماضي فعمليه الاطلاق تمت
من داخل روسيا بدلا من اوكرانيا اتجاه
موسكو المسؤولون الامريكيون يعتقدون ان
اوكرانيا طورت خلايا داخل روسيا تتكون من
مزيج من المؤيدين لاوكرانيا ونشطاء مدربين
تدريبا جيدا في هذا النوع من الحروب
معلومات سي ان ان تشير الى ان اوكرانيا
انشات طرق تهريب خلف خطوط العدو يمكن
استخدامها لارسال طائرات بدون طيار او
مكوناتها الى داخل روسيا حيث يمكن تجميعها
هناك بعد ذلك عملاء كييف يعتقد انه يتم
تزويدهم بطائرات بدون طيار اوكرانيه الصنع
دون استعمال المسيرات التي سلمتها واشنطن
المصادر تشير ايضا الى انه ليس من الواضح
ما اذا كانت هجمات مسيرات اخرى نفذت في
الايام الاخيره من خلالها هؤلاء العملاء
خاصه الهجوم الذي استهدف حيا سكانيا
بالقرب من موسكو وضربه اخرى على مصاف
النفط جنوبي روسيا هي مواجهه عسكريه كل
شيء فيها مباح وابتكار الاساليب الجديده
اصبح اوكرانيا بامتياز بالنظر الى قوه
الاله العسكريه الروسيه في المواجهات
التقليديه بلال البجدين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
قصص الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات